let's get some practice now thinking
about how ions typically form how they
might form compounds and how we need
those compounds so let's start with
something in Group one in this first
column this first column is also known
as alkali metals and so let's start with
potassium K is the symbol for potassium
now things in Group one here one way to
think about is their outermost shell has
one electron in it so they wouldn't mind
losing that electron so when they ionize
they tend to lose an electron and become
a cation a positive ion and so let's
look at a situation where I have some
potassium that has been ionized and I
could I could write it just like this
we've seen that in previous videos and
we can refer to this just as a potassium
ion we could refer to this as potassium
one plus we could refer this refer to
this as a potassium cation now let's go
on to the other side of the periodic
table things that would really love to
grab an electron so things in a group in
the halides which is this column right
over here so these are the halides they
have seven electrons in their outermost
shell they would love to have eight so
they tend to be really good at grabbing
electrons and so let's say we're dealing
with chlorine and chlorine is able to
ionize so it's able to grab an electron
when chlorine grabs an electron it will
be a negatively charged ion so you could
write as chlorine one minus but the way
that we generally refer to an anion a
negatively charged ion instead of saying
this is instead of just calling this the
chlorine anion we would call this
chloride so this we referred to as klore
poor ID now as you can imagine with
potassium having a positive one charge
or one plus charge and this having a
negative charge they're going to be
attracted to each other
and they can actually form an ionic
compound and of the ionic compound they
would form we would write as you'd write
your positive ion first and then you
would write your negative ion and this
right over here would be described as
potassium chloride let me write that
down
potassium potassium chloride now you
might be saying well I just root let me
rewrite though write the whole thing so
you know the chloride part you say okay
this is going to be an anion because
instead of writing chlorine which is the
name of this element
I wrote this IDE at the end to say hey
this is an anion so I know that this is
this is the chlorine anion this is
chloride why didn't I do something
similar for potassium well the way the
convention works is if someone says
potassium chloride you know you're
dealing with an ionic compound and if
the chlorine has a negative one charge
an ionic compound the whole thing is
going to be neutral so this one over
here is one minus then you know this
over here since they're one for one this
is going to be one plus so you know that
you're dealing with a potassium cation
and I you could say a core and a
chloride ion or a chlorine anion you
could refer to it other ways there are
various ways but this is potassium
chloride you have a positively charged
potassium and you have a negatively
charged chlorine which we would call a
chloride in the next few videos we'll do
many many more examples of this and once
it'll be a lot a little bit more
complicated